hello mother people of the whole entire
world welcome to our beautiful show
called genius brain were brains of
geniuses brain each other in this case
give each other head enjoy each other's
dick it's called that's what genius
brain is just it's just a lot of brain
[ __ ] yeah it's a smart goal that
sucks your dick but my name is Joe jizz
okawa and this is my buddy David so if
this is the first time listening welcome
you just gotta intro what the hell we're
all about
yeah we're just a bunch of dumbasses
just talking yo today's subject is very
interesting um we're just gonna hop
right into it there's gonna be no filter
so and it's really not so much just on
my part but I saw a video that you put
up with you and Jess mm-hmm and it was
interesting because it was a lot of the
stuff that we talk about behind the
scenes you talk about the Valentine's
one had the Valentine's one we're
talking about that the vlog where you
were talking about your relationship yup
and kind of how I mean I'm gonna let you
get into it but it's it's it's it's the
image that we put up that people don't
know what goes on behind the scenes oh
yeah and what people don't know is that
I know that you see a lot of people on
YouTube and you guys wonder if people
are like real friends behind so we kick
it all the time ya know and I'll be it
whenever I'm in trouble or whenever we
need help we always help each other out
and so a lot of the stuff that I've been
I'm not somebody who knows everything
about relationships but when when
somebody in a group is having trouble we
like to give advice so when I'm in
trouble he gives me advice and when he's
in trouble it works the other way around
we vent like a [ __ ] we go to
dinner like about a girlfriends
dude that's therapy though it is man
there's a lot of dudes that I don't now
I know why would you see it on these
sitcoms why these dudes go out and they
talk [ __ ] about the people that they
love yeah it's cuz it's just it's a
steam release yeah it's like when you
cook rice and it goes yes any other like
a [ __ ] like an insta pot that's what
it feels like you release the pressure
yeah and we would do this on a regular
basis
and it's funny because one of the people
that is Gio's there yeah and you know
she didn't want to be there yeah and
embark couldn't talk 100% or he
shouldn't be talking a hundred percent
about geo but he does in front of us cuz
he wants to join in and we're just like
no that's just weird yeah we had to
though just because like we needed our
we needed our time so there's a little
background so Joe got together with Jess
basically around the exact same time I
got together with Mariel yeah and prior
to these two women in our lives
they are our longest standing
relationship yes and I know that may not
see like something great but for us it's
a huge thing I'm so used to having
fleeting relationships yeah so when
problems would arise I had the option of
running away and I would always choose
option B run the [ __ ] away I think it's
it's the same for partners - right let
has Mary o been in a longer really she
actually you're her first I'm her free
oh boy first real she would date and all
that and then so her understanding or
sticking around and all that it's just
not the same as you right exactly so we
we kind of had I think you said Jess was
like that too right so she had fleeting
relationship both of us we never been in
a relationship that lasted over two
years yeah as soon as the butterflies
and everything is gone were gone you
[ __ ] left with the butterflies yeah
yeah you left with the cocoon yes we did
that [ __ ] and it was because a lot of
its we had a self explore a lot um you
know when I when I when I used to just
bounce on these relationships and he's
committed these things that were
supposed to be long-term committed
things yeah I thought it was because
everything was wrong with them and when
it turned out to be was I had commitment
issues and I chose the option B of
running the [ __ ] away because it was
easier than standing there and talking
to the business person face to face and
learning about myself and also learning
more about that person I didn't want to
invest that time it's just cuz you're a
dumb [ __ ] and I'm a [ __ ] elite was
was the option that I had in my mind I
always an option or I just think oh
we're not meant to be yeah we're just
not meant to be we're not getting along
oh it's not true love we're not meant to
everybody right yeah it's just not
working
anymore yeah what do you mean it's not
working it it never was working you were
just convincing yourself that it was
yeah and I think the what I've been
seeing a lot with you guys especially
when I saw that video come out was it's
it's kind of like that big step for you
guys were because both of you have not
been in long-term committed
relationships you're figuring out all
the work that it takes to have a
successful relationship yeah and it's
[ __ ] hard it's [ __ ] hard man it is
because I think I'm learning so much
about myself but it is the hardest thing
that I've ever had to deal with like I
would much rather get into a fight with
someone I had to get punched in the face
I rather get jumped I rather get I'd
rather have a man mug me in an alleyway
and point a gun to my face and take my
money I would much rather have that then
go through heartache and and and
arguments and and headaches it's it's
that it's that confusion of not
understanding that person that you want
to [ __ ] kill and then not
understanding why you feel that way or
how come why how one individual can
control how the way you feel about
things yeah cuz for me I'm thinking you
know I'm a pretty logical person but
when this person comes into my mix I
logic goes out the [ __ ] door
yeah dude one of the things that you
said that cracked me the [ __ ] up dude
it's because this was during a time to
where he and I were going through the
same problems yeah we couldn't
understand like what the [ __ ] was this
creature that we choose to stay around
with all the time and why yeah but this
fool he was at his apartment and he goes
he looks out the window and he goes it's
nice out here his balcony I wish I could
just [ __ ] throw this woman off his
balcony right died laughing you know
look out the balcony like he was Batman
I thought he was gonna say something
really profound and he was like [ __ ]
off this [ __ ] balcony right now
and I do exactly what he meant yeah they
know how to push our [ __ ] button yeah
it's true it just drives you crazy I'm
pretty sure we do the same ass thing to
them over sorry thinking how do I
[ __ ] shut this man oh yeah do
one of the things that I found out that
I think that both of us do
Missy and I both do and it's really
dependent on mood is that each person in
the relationship always think that
they're they always think that they are
the most logical person in the
conversation and the other one is it
yeah so so what happens is it is too
small or too genius [ __ ] brains
you're talking to each other two smart
asses yeah and they're really trying to
belittle each other basically we're
calling each other dumb like oh no you
don't understand every argument starts
and ends with that you don't understand
what I'm saying no you don't understand
what I'm saying cuz you both want to be
right exactly yeah and that's the thing
that I know that notice that notice that
she and I did all the time and we still
do to this day that we're trying to fix
is that bad habit of always trying to be
right all the time yeah and what I'm
figuring out is that it's not about
being right it's about solving this
problem that we had together mm-hmm
you know and that kind of came with a
lot of the learning process of figuring
out - with compromise especially with
these arguments right so what I used to
think about compromises was I don't want
to compromise this because why have two
people not be happy with the result and
just you know just get half of something
and you get the other half but a
compromise really isn't that a
compromise is coming to a conclusion
that's better than the conclusion that
you would have had by yourself yeah it's
like you're both happy yeah like I could
do this for business right I can always
negotiate talk about something figure
out a win-win such a wind win outcome
where we both leave happier yeah I could
do that but when I don't know why in a
relationship I can't apply the same
things that I can do and it's almost the
same thing because it's a it's a it's a
relationship like if we go over a
dispute over something like we could
just sit down and say all right what do
you want out of this right and we can
figure it out cuz it's logical and at
least in our business relationship right
but like there are shitty relationships
business relationships where it is very
emotional and then you don't
work with them anymore it's hard because
during them you're remembering yesterday
when she called you a fat [ __ ] for
eating that extra doughnut it's like yes
son of a [ __ ] and I think that's what
it is it's the emotional part of it yeah
like you gotta think clear you can't
think clear this way because you're just
so butthurt by the smallest things that
they do yeah and I'm like I feel like I
feel like it took me a long time to
realize something so simple like it's
like obvious but when you're so angry
you can't think yeah and and I in the
same problem that we have is like we
both are the biggest [ __ ] victims
like you did me so wrong yeah like oh my
god it's unforgivable like that's that's
where it's like we take it personal well
let me ask you something then just to
wrap it back to what we were talking
before so recently you put a post where
you gave her a [ __ ] Valentine's gift
yeah and what you wrote in that post
which I didn't know you never gave her a
Valentine's gift before I think I did
but it wasn't like a special one like
that yeah well what was the reason for
them I hated her guts
I was so petty that when when when
special times came around I was like you
do not deserve this because there's so
many other times when I do give you [ __ ]
and it's not rewarded Oh or like we go
on vacations and all this special stuff
that happens but I don't feel any type
of gratitude from that so I'm like if
we're not Valentine's everyday why am I
gonna fake Valentines on a real day just
because it's a day that I should show
you affection yeah and I don't know like
I think I think there's just a lot of
like resentment and no forgiveness on my
part right so like I'm holding grudges
or or maybe like when Valentine's comes
around like like we got into a fight but
I realize like you know with love
there's forgiveness and just
cuz just cuz like like you're fighting
doesn't mean that the birthdays not a
birthday anymore yeah you know to me
like it's still a birthday like we
should still celebrate certain things
for some reason that that was not on my
mind I think it was hard for you just
because when I was having a conversation
with you and Jess it was you know when
we were talking about certain things
that you guys can openly talk about
right because you guys also mentioned to
me that you guys tried therapy before
and it just wasn't a fit so you know
when we were speaking openly about
things I felt like a lot of things were
coming out that you guys wanted to say
but there wasn't immediate they kind of
yeah you helped out a lot man and it's
the it's because you know when we were
both very smart people yeah it's too
smart in a way where we get our [ __ ]
way you guys can break each other down
to the [ __ ] molecule dude like when
you when you guys were sitting there and
you guys were arguing with each other
yeah it's amazing how precise your
arguments are so you know you guys could
break down everything that happened from
a year ago like it happened yesterday
dude yeah and the first thing I said
wasn't a hold on a second Matt when did
that happen you're like this was like
two years ago hold on a second then why
does it sound like it happened yesterday
do you remember all the nuances in this
argument from two years ago and what you
guys were showing was that you actually
didn't forgive each other
yeah and that's the thing that was a
huge clicking moment from yellow's I
weigh hold on so you guys actually
haven't moved past your problem you
could remember that fresh that means
you've still thought about it
periodically within those two years yep
yeah and I mean that was my learning
experience right is like we didn't know
how to forgive and forget is because we
just kept we just kept on like like
we're doing the same [ __ ] like you heard
how we you know the thing is we're to
like the thing that brought us together
is is we're very similar yeah but so our
problems oh yeah
so we're two identical it's like it's
like the things that we love about each
other it turned on us so for example
like you know like we both come from a
broken home we both come from a single
parent and that's not an excuse what it
is is something that brought us together
cuz she told me in the past like guys
that she dated and and and they would
reject her for her past but when it when
it was me like I I was interested that's
something you connected her cuz I
connected with her so and an ice I
empathize with her cuz I was like [ __ ]
you know we come from the same [ __ ]
other guys would date her and they find
they don't even want to hear her pass
they get freaked out by it as if she's
painted like she's de Saint it's all
right like but for me I I welcomed her
with open arms because hey I'm just as
tainted baby
but what it's like yes I can I can kind
of relate in a lot of upbringing things
with her right so yeah so she's got a
team she's got a buddy but with those uh
what do you call it abandonment issues
that we have we turn on each other yeah
so it's it's like if she feels that I'm
abandoning her and vice versa we turn on
each other so that's where we had to
kind of learn like oh [ __ ] we both
created these defense mechanisms where
before you [ __ ] me over I'm a [ __ ] you
over mm-hmm and in its - two people with
the same personality trait so it's like
how do you heal from that you know that
was the cool thing about I think I know
hopefully you know just noses to which I
you know I'm pretty sure she does but
because you guys do converse a lot about
your problems there there is a certain
level of understanding that you guys
have with each other right mm-hmm so one
of the the positives about the thing
that I got from talking to you too is
that you guys did attempt to look at
each other's past to understand why they
act this way in the present yeah it
helped us not take things so personally
after a while now before we continue my
friends this podcast is brought to you
by Sanford now have you ever walked down
the street and have a random stranger
come up to you and say you know what
dude you smell good I guarantee you that
said no because you haven't heard of
scent bird now for me check this out I
like to smell different all the time and
what I mean by that is have you ever
bought a bottle of cologne and after you
used it you found out two years later
you still have 70% of it left because
you
you know dang well you're not gonna use
that gajillion ounce bottle of cologne
and after a while maybe and even after a
few months you want to smell different
you're tired of smelling the same way
and you still want to smell good well
guess it what my friends scent bird is
gonna fix that for you now for me if
you're asking
well David how do you choose your scent
well when I go on scent bird comm and I
want to choose the fragrances I want
this is what I do I don't look at the
name brands I go by the types of smell
that I enjoy they have that search
engine option for me I click citrus I
click sandalwood I click bergamont fresh
clean smells and from that list I choose
my colognes and ladies that goes for you
with your perfumes as well well check
this out you can choose the clone you
want to try and they'll also send you a
30-day supply that's a hundred and
twenty sprays enough to apply more than
four times daily for a month to keep you
smelling fresh and with an exclusive
offer just for our listeners you can get
50% off your first month today
that's only 750 for your first fragrance
go to scent bird comm / brain and use my
code brain for 50% off your first month
again that's SC e + t-bird dot-com /
brain for you to get your first cologne
or perfume for just 750 my friends sign
on and smell amazing sad bird because
Jess's personal story I mean if she
feels comfortable later on to tell it to
you guys she will but her personal story
is it's pretty deep you know and without
knowing that background in history you
would just think she's a mean ass person
but but with a heart of gold it's like
why are you so nice but mean at the same
time I don't understand
and people are some when I was younger
too my dad used to tell me my dad used
to tell me he goes don't don't get with
the girl who has divorced parents and
the first thing I would say ride the bus
like you judgmental [ __ ] well how
[ __ ] dare you
in the trash can of a man you know but
he just didn't know how to phrase it
what he meant was when you are with
somebody who has a troubled past you are
also taking on that baggage with you so
be prepared for that
yeah so unless you're prepared to
take on that person's woes then don't
get with that person you have to be
mentally strong for that obviously he
didn't explain it like that but that's
basically what he was trying to say you
know that's kind of like when you guys
are going with this you guys had the
boat both of you have trouble pass oh
yeah you know what I was explaining to
you guys was that you guys have an
uphill battle right now because you need
to come from a place of understanding
and patience but both you are too broken
human beings that are trying to fix each
other mm-hmm and that's hard you know
it's a very difficult thing because what
what what are the examples that you're
you're coming from you know two broken
homes it's like okay well which one of
us understands what it's like to grow up
with the house of just two parents no
one no none of us do and that's the hard
part
do we don't have any good role models
yeah and I mean this is a conversation
that I had with my mom like um just a
week ago she was praising me she was
like talking to me like man I don't know
um you and Jess you're you're pulling it
together you made a great life for
yourself and she's like you did this
without a good role model like she was
like I sucked as a mom and she's like I
couldn't hold down a relationship with
your dad and then you know I didn't know
finances like I didn't know all these
things and you surpass me in in life she
was just giving me so much props and I
felt really good because you know Asian
parents don't really give you props and
say those words until you're about to
die they're about to die yeah and then
and she's like she's like I think it's
good to fight you need to fight with
Jess like she's like I fight all the
time it feels amazing I used to hold in
[ __ ] all the time
she goes I fight with your stepdad all
the time mommy's a [ __ ] now okay it's
normal to fight and she goes it's
awesome and she's like it's just a it's
just gonna be a long road ahead but
she's like but have fun yeah and and
then I mean it's it's cool to have that
because you know I didn't really have
the closest relationship with my mom so
talking to her and just hearing those
words gives me that idea of we're not
that weird and we're not that different
knowing that like everybody everybody
around me has problems everybody is
going through similar things my problem
doesn't seem so big anymore when it
seems big it feels out of control
yes when those venting sessions were for
us yes because when we had the same
problems always like thank God [ __ ] oh
so just isn't a [ __ ] she's just a
normal [ __ ] annoying girl yeah so you
know that was what those vending
sessions were it kind of made me feel
like I wasn't the only one going through
it yeah and so it kind of normalized the
problems that we were having yeah cuz
when your heated and in the moment you
just think it's just you you think so
while everyone else is having a blast
because you see their instagrams you see
their vlogs you see their relationships
and you think you think they're they
bought they got it all together that
shit's not real it's not [ __ ] real
and I get you know and I'm not knocking
on those people that put that image out
because it's not their job to show you
the real stuff a lot of the times people
come on Instagram and social media
things because they want to see
something really positive yeah so
they're doing their job but you
shouldn't base your relationship off of
what you see from these pictures those
are just moments in their life and
arguably to is a business for people you
know so even when they're pissed there's
probably still taking that [ __ ]
picture with them feeding each other
pizza while they're sucking each other
off [ __ ] you know what I mean like oh
yeah we know a lot of people that
[ __ ] like we joke about it off camera
yeah there are people that just got into
a heated [ __ ] fight but they have to
they had to just take this [ __ ]
picture really quick yeah deal yeah and
get back to the fight it is normal man
like it's hard working with your couple
it doesn't mean that they're about to
break up but like that just happens that
just happens to everybody even like in
weddings like it's supposed to be this
awesome moment they're not social media
stars but you know they're fighting
behind the scenes like it happens a lot
yeah I just that was the cool thing when
we were figuring that out with each
other you know and I think that there
was a point too specifically when you
guys were going through things that I
assumed that you know as Muriel and I
were progressing and moving past our
problems you guys were coming along with
us and then we were talking about other
holistic you guys are still at stage two
you know yeah yeah so I think that for
me was a big shot you know and for you
know on the outside looking in I can't
judge anything until I talk ya guys and
so you know that one night when we came
over I just wanted to
see you guys how you guys were doing no
I mean it's it's awesome that we did
have that conversation because you know
sometimes you need that friend that
comes in and sees it from outside in
yeah
it was it was important to have you know
it was a bit worried for me it was a big
worry for me because um you know there's
a lot of the times too especially when I
know with like me and you when we have
big problems we turn it into humor and
we joke about it
yeah but within that joking humor
there's there's something real about it
mhm and so when that was kind of when
that triggered in my head I was like
okay well let's just extend it out and
see what's going on and it led to a
small conversation and obviously it led
to something bigger but you know I think
that the main thing that I saw was you
you still guys do you guys were still
having the same problems we were yeah it
was just how you guys dealt with it and
took it was way different yeah you know
did did bickering a and B have to turn
into this huge thing you know and so I
was like wait hold on that's an argument
that Muriel and I had but it didn't lead
to this huge fight right so it's like
extra baggage over over why you keeping
the cups here or whatever or like you
know it's it's not it doesn't make sense
to be that angry for someone that said
this over dinner there was there was
something bigger you know yeah for sure
and it all boils down to forgiveness man
we both weren't forgiving we're both not
moving on we're both and we had to kind
of wake up and and and challenge
ourselves to do something different
approach it differently stop being
selfish your selfless right these are
all it's all common sense really if you
look at the Bible or whatever the heat
of the moment though yeah everything is
just everything is just okay be selfless
like love is unconditional like do all
these things but what does that really
[ __ ] mean what does it really really
need to put others first yeah and I
mentioned this on Barton Geo's podcast
like one of the things that I've learned
to practice and I learned a lot of this
stuff from my parents and some other
people too this isn't just some kind of
Epiphany I had on my own it's you know
what does it really mean to give
somebody love that you're with and this
is the hard part for people a lot of the
times people treat their
significant other as a pet and what I
mean by that is when my partner does
something good that I like I give them a
treat I say good boy good girl good yeah
good girl that's the easy thing but what
that develops is something into
something actually really negative
because you're thinking that if this
person only does what I say that they
should do then I should praise them and
that becomes a problem because the the
hardest part and the best part that
people should practice is giving person
love when they need it the most and that
is difficult because it's hard to do
that being a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah but
there's a reason why they're doing that
and there's a reason why you need to
actually go out of your way to to uplift
them during this really hard time I'm
not saying it's easy because it's hard
for me to and Muriel had to do that for
me the other day because I was freaking
out about stupid [ __ ] I was being
[ __ ] angry I was just a long story
short things weren't going my way that
day things were just failing one after
the other yeah I was just in the house
cursing up a storm and then Muriel all
she did was lay next to me and then she
just you know gave me kisses on the
cheek he started like petting my head
like a dog bad example but and it helped
me calm down instead of turning on you
and being mad at you for being mad
exactly
it's I think it all boils down to her
upbringing mm-hmm like I had this
longest conversation with my mom about
my upbringing and I don't remember a lot
of stuff cuz I was a child but she was
in tears man she was like in tears one
day just like she made this realization
of how badly she's damaged me and my
brother and conditional love you know
cuz mm-hmm she she's never got
unconditional love mm-hmm
only by her dad not by her my my grandma
and my dad in her dad which was my
gambling alcoholic grandpa okay she
loved him to death yeah she said he's
always accepted her always like
supported her whatever and then he
passed so like she lost her uh her
unconditional loving man my father was
conditional love my grandma was
conditional love so my mom
he was surrounded by that conditional
love world and so you know I think this
happens to a lot of Asian kids are just
traditional kids like when you grow up
if you don't perform a certain way your
parents want you to perform you're
almost like hated hmm so it's like oh I
want you to be this doctor or musician
or I want you to have perfect grades or
like and if you don't perform those
things you feel rejected by your parents
and by your family right so what this
does is it creates you to think that you
you know like someone that you love is a
pet yeah they do something good you give
them a treat they do something bad you
hate them for it right so this concept
of loving someone whether they're up or
down or whatever to me it's very foreign
I get angry when people are not
performing well mmm you know what I mean
like in it shouldn't because that that
actually makes them perform even worse
you know right like so like like let's
say like I'm a coach right and my and my
athletes doing bad if I scold them and
kick him in his ass like he's gonna do
worse because it destroys their
confidence but that's all I know and I
didn't realize I was doing the exact
same thing that I hated so much about my
parents to Jess no and it automatically
happens even my thoughts I got a I got a
rework my thoughts it's not that I don't
love her I just don't know how to embody
that cuz it's not this is learned
behavior it's not natural unconditional
love is an is a learned behavior it's
not natural to the human soul you know
you know I mean like people might
disagree or whatever but it's almost
like if if gambling is normal to in your
family you're probably much gonna be a
gambler when you grow up right same with
if your parents are compulsively lying
all the time you're gonna be at all
gonna do that's right
and that's what I mean by like this
expression of love unconditionally
whether someone is up or down and
showing and verbalizing and and doing
all that stuff like that is something
that you have to grow up with or learn
and it takes a long fun
in time yeah long time when I met
justice dad I was observing their
relationship and I was like [ __ ] dude
like no matter what um
he's so [ __ ] warm and accepting and
you don't ever feel like this authority
figure it feels more like a friend yeah
well it's it's weird because he's very
nurturing
he's a nurturing man but he's a man like
he's a man's man like he's a [ __ ]
cook like he's like works with his hands
like he's just somehow he figured out to
play both mom and dad yes oh yeah - you
know yeah and he knows you know like he
knows how to speak in a way where like
he's teaching you wisdom but not
lecturing you and he knows how to tell
stories where like you're you know
you're learning but you don't feel
attacked this is so foreign to me yeah
because you know like growing up Asian
parenting especially aggressive Asian
parents right we're maybe us is a little
bit different but but like the way our
parents talk to us is as if we're not
even human anymore we're [ __ ]
low-lives were stupid we don't know
jack-shit it's almost as if they hate us
you know and then that's if that's what
all you know that's how you start
talking to people you love know like I'm
pretty sure you got it from Mariel to
likely she would if you piss her off
it's almost like she doesn't like you
guys aren't in love anymore your house I
knew this this and this you're such a
dumbass or whatever right so you start
lecturing each other it creates this
separation and resentment and hurt and
it's like fog dude like it's hard cuz it
takes you to a place that you don't want
to be in and it's a place where you look
at your partner and you say I want to
hurt you because it's gonna make me feel
better and that's yeah that's a very bad
place to be in you want to get even
yeah and it's like so bad it's it's it's
scary yeah and my thing was - that I
learned was if you're with somebody and
their happiness doesn't make you happy
I'm not saying go overboard and please
them and take everything away from you
that's not what I mean I'm talking about
the sense of compromise we're then being
happy with you you guys having a
cohesive relationship isn't the goal
then you're probably in a bad
relationship or there's a lot of
learning that needs to go on between
both of you because when you have that
vindictive behavior where revenge is is
what makes you happy like oh well now
this person knows how I feel and they're
hurting so I bet you that they're gonna
do better next time
that's already something bad yeah it
never ever works out well in that case
people don't learn through that way
that's why they always say you catch B's
better with honey than vinegar right and
it's the same with people I used to do
this with my brother and I'm a little
bit different in this case I actually
had to learn how to communicate with my
older brother a lot better so how I
learned is very different and Bart knows
about this - I'm the type of person
where somebody tells me I can't do
something I go [ __ ] you want to do it
you know David you can't do a cartwheel
you're 260 pounds you were about to see
the most funny that's how he supports
you he keeps roasting you all day it's
so [ __ ] funny dude it's like dude I
will do the most beautiful cartwheel you
will ever see in your life you know and
that's how I work and I used to do this
thing where my brother where I thought
because my brother I grew up together
obviously I would say I bet you my
brothers are saying cry yeah so I would
I would [ __ ] berate my older brother
I'm like dude you little [ __ ] stop being
a little [ __ ] and [ __ ] pick yourself
up you little [ __ ] and that it would
crush him you know you know what I found
out I'm actually like that but for
things that are pretty laughable don't
don't you ever talk about my dreams my
sugarcane farm my [ __ ] mud hut dude
that [ __ ] sugarcane fight that you
cut is so funny because it's such a
weird misunderstanding right so I mean
this dude told me this story well here
so Joe is a type of human being we're
and we're both like this in the sense of
when we find something that we like we
go [ __ ] full force with this yeah
it's a part of our personality yeah but
the problem with him is his hobbies
almost seemed like a [ __ ] joke
and so when you came out he was like
hyper excited talking to Jess like yo
I'm a dude
okay [ __ ] it's gonna be dope I really
enjoyed the stuff and then just just
laughed at him yeah apparently she's
just like what the [ __ ] are you talking
about and for her she was laughing cuz
she thought he was making a joke yeah
it's a sugarcane farm but he was serious
and he just went you're just [ __ ]
[ __ ] on all of my sugarcane dreams
you bitter [ __ ] it's not so funny I
just had to I just had to come to the
realization of like yeah man I got
ridiculous dreams like what wait you
you're gonna view a farm dream right now
I got all kinds of dreams homie piano
dreams musical dreams all kinds of
dreams fishing dreams it's so weird
because you would think the more
successful somebody becomes you want to
use that money for dope [ __ ] you're
trying to go back in time yeah you're
trying to strip everything away from you
you want to live in a [ __ ] cave mud
hut while you figure out how to irrigate
this water canal to your house like dude
we have plumbing like that now we have
that here I told her my goal this year
is I'm gonna go to the mountains right
here the Angels forest oh my god with
just a backpack and sleep out there dude
you're gonna get eaten by a coyote she
said I was like no I'm not don't don't
crush my dreams the [ __ ] dreams
attacked by a coyote or a [ __ ]
mountain lion it's weird though cuz that
also goes into like being with the
relationship and you start to realize
how how much your significant others
words can affect you in both positive
and negative yeah cuz when you hear
you're your partner just praise you for
good things it lights you up yeah when
they [ __ ] talk [ __ ] though mm-hmm
that's your [ __ ] makes me boil dude
man I had to learn a lot of I'm still
learning now but like how much my words
can affect someone yeah cuz like I think
like I can be very tactless from time to
time especially you yeah especially if
I'm frustrated or like if I don't care I
just say what's on my mind and then I
think I've cultivated this like meaner
type of speaking style with Jess because
originally it wasn't all
that way she's she's like oh she's like
a blunt person but she was never a mean
person you know like when I first met
her and we were talking and all that
stuff but um yeah I think I think just
me being the way that I am she kind of
absorbs some of that too
yeah and so we just have this like
roasty kind of relationship now that
gets too far sometimes mm-hmm so like at
times it's fun but then I don't know I
think also to like like we were we used
to be much more tender toward each other
so there's no balance you know if you're
just roasting all day then it just turns
into [ __ ] talking like a cloud you guys
are the 24/7 but or like or like
sometimes it's just not right to just
even say bad words toward each other
when you're angry or whatever
yeah there's it's time in place yeah I
know um because I would hear this
argument a lot in couples will they go
where they say well I said that the
other day and then was perfectly fine I
was like well there's a time and place
man an intention
yeah and how you're feeling intentions
it's not just words and words is like
20% of the communication yeah it's how
you say it it's how it's what when in
the conversation did you say whatever
but like all those stuff I took it I had
to learn because now it's like oh I'm
gonna try to build her up and and help
her be confident and all that's cuz um I
remember she used to say this stuff like
she was like all like I lost a pop piece
of me I lost who I was
I'm like what you're talking about
wouldn't believe yeah I didn't get it
because you know I'm in my own world a
lot but when she you know she she did a
lot for me like she moved gave up her
whole entire life she had a professional
career like a lot of people like oh you
[ __ ] left this life for being with
the youtuber like a lot of people don't
realize I wasn't making that much when I
first met her I was driving a crawler I
was still making just a couple thousand
a month like I wasn't even that big oh
you met her during the Corolla days yeah
oh [ __ ]
I mean that's when I started making a
little bit more money and then I was
like you know what I must I'm gonna make
I'm gonna give myself one treat a month
and I'm gonna
traveling I started travelling different
places and then I remember that yeah and
then that's when I had like extra 200
bucks a month to go travel and then I
would visit her go to go to Austin Texas
and [ __ ] like that she would visit me
and then like you know we would just do
simple [ __ ] like go to the beach go on a
hike we didn't spend that much money and
then she says she misses the poor Jo
because it was it was different back
then yeah but like yeah a lot of people
don't know that that like when she first
dated me the first first year or
whatever like I was I was just driving a
Corolla I wasn't like you know making
much and then we're just having fun and
building a relationship just being
together and then um fast-forward to now
like I have money I have all these
things and then there was one point in
our relationship where like [ __ ] dude on
paper like we have all this stuff we
have a nice place we have whatever but
why are we so unhappy and then like I
was like I can't vlog this fake [ __ ]
like it's not me and then for her to
like she's she's she's always been real
like from the moment I started recording
her she's never faked her personality
you know so when we were recording and
all that [ __ ] like I I started feeling
fraudulent to being like hey everybody
what's up cuz like that I am a hyper
[ __ ] and I am happy but like I
can't do that in authentically yeah when
I'm when I'm hurting inside and we're
fighting like I can't be like Oh things
are [ __ ] awesome
you know like yeah because I'll become
those people that I hate so much like
you know all those other lifestyle
vloggers that are perfect and all of a
sudden they have a breakup video what
the [ __ ] happened you know they were
going through problems you know they
were cheating we know but behind the
scenes a lot of [ __ ] [ __ ] rights just
don't happen out of nowhere in those
type of videos yeah and they're like oh
it was a mutual breakup we still love
each other but we might get back
together it's like shut up dude yeah you
know something was going on something
really bad maybe who knows but I didn't
want to be that because since day one JK
has always been real ly
we were like [ __ ] it we're gonna cuss
we're gonna say where the [ __ ] we want
bucket if sponsor sponsor us they do who
cares we're just gonna stay as authentic
as possible because this ain't Hollywood
this is [ __ ] YouTube right and then
fast-forward to like a couple years ago
now there's lifestyle vloggers all these
people frot like faking pranks faking
this and then I was just like man [ __ ]
this dude I don't want to be one of
those [ __ ] we burnt out we we don't
want to do this I was starting to focus
on the relationship or at least trying
to yeah and I just didn't know what to
do really
you know like how do how like there's no
recipe for this [ __ ]
no there's it's like what do you do
spend more time okay you spend more time
you fight more what do you do like you
know anyway like the problem is I see
your face all the [ __ ] time yeah
that's the solution you know yeah what
do you do like you you try to be
romantic well how do I do that you can't
be romantic if you're if you don't feel
good about each other like you know what
what do you do and then you just keep
living life and then you fight and then
you don't fight and then it just
there's no mentor really like there's no
parents that can help us out you know
we're all at the same stage I don't have
anybody older that's trying to teach me
you know and even people that I know
that are older they might be going
through divorces themselves you know
like some of my family members went to
divorce in their 50s you know you know
and it's like not that they don't have
any wisdom for me I think everyone's
just trying to figure it out too so no
one knows what to do and I was just like
[ __ ] I got to figure it out for us and I
mean big thanks to you when you talked
to us - you were like a good mediator
right so like well we'll always have
these fights where we have these long
conversations and we have a solution and
we don't solve anything
yeah because it's solved here not here
so everything is like okay next time we
won't do this and that but like we don't
feel the root of the problem wasn't
wasn't addressed exactly and we don't
forgive
we didn't go okay like you know I love
you no matter what
it was more like okay next time you
don't do that or else I won't love you
anymore
so it was a very [ __ ] conditioned
conditional and like these are the
things that we had to wipe away and be
like I'm sorry I'm completely sorry next
time if things happen again it's okay
because I love you because I love you if
things happen again we're in it together
we're here to learn together it's also
human it's normal it's [ __ ] normal
yeah that's why I said like when I was
hearing you about your guys's problems
that it wasn't it wasn't any different
than anybody else's it was just the fact
that you guys held in so much hate
towards each other because you didn't
[ __ ] move on bad yeah but I so you
know there was like certain examples
that you were giving me and I just home
I in my mind I was like don't really
that big of a deal well how you guys
could catalogue every [ __ ] thing that
happened in that conversation to that
point showed me one thing was that you
guys were looking to burn each other
throughout that whole day it's like oh
yeah well guess what memory memory
memory it was just so you guys could you
you guys were just collecting a case
yeah you could present it at the end of
the day or two good [ __ ] lawyer is
bad and you're like well guess what
[ __ ] guess we'll remember when
you did this check [ __ ]
and I'm like okay well now you guys are
just battling each other then it got the
point and I remember it was like a
serious thing that I said I said I don't
even know if you guys are actually a
couple anymore
yeah and it was a it was a thing that I
I felt weird saying but I had to say it
at the time it was if you look back on
it right now and you look at your
relationship are you guys really a
couple or are you guys just living
together because you're trying to just
get by to the day-to-day yeah and and
that's a very scary point because now
it's just we're staying together because
it's convenient but we're not sure if
we're really compatible because we're
not working towards that yet and so what
happens is a lot of the times and I've
seen this with a lot of people is that
people get comfortable in that weird
homeostasis of well at least we're not
fighting so we must be good yeah and
that becomes normal yeah and that's
scary cuz they never fix their problem
right we always I think that's the
difference is that we're we can't live
with problems yeah so it's always
killing us
we just don't know how to fit we didn't
know how to handle it yeah we didn't
know how to approach it like I think
that's the biggest thing about like our
situation is that not only the the
coming from a broken home but like we
never work through problems with our
exes hmm so although me and Jess we love
each other yeah we don't know how to fix
the hurt from the purse for the person
you love yeah that's the hard part it's
like I want to stay with her which she
wants to stay with me or else why would
we be together we're not here because
it's comfortable it's uncomfortable yeah
it's if if I was gonna be in a
comfortable situation she would be the
worst person to be with
yeah you know I mean there's so many
people out there that I that I don't
love that I don't care about but I think
we'll get along and it would be
comfortable you know she's the opposite
I [ __ ] love her to death but then she
drives me crazy yeah but at the same
time it's like it's it's hard only
because we care about each other so much
and we're we're trying to be what's the
word peaceful mmm-hmm and it's not
peaceful because we don't forgive yeah
so so and that's that's because we never
forgave our past exes or whatever right
like we didn't know how to work through
that and be like it's cool and then move
on but as time is progressing and we're
learning how to forgive these problems
are becoming smaller and smaller yeah
like and we need positive reinforcement
meaning like if we keep getting pissed
about the same problems and we're
dealing with the same problems the same
way we're being [ __ ] because we're
not fixing anything we're just
approaching it the same exact way that's
stupid
yeah now I'm doing different methods
every single time like I'm trying and
testing so I have to bite my tongue
breathe and think of something different
to say or do so if she gets mad at me
for something
I'm trying this new thing where I'm just
like breathe before you open your mouth
which should be common sense right
everybody should do it it's hard but I'm
just like we just loose ah let me just
say that do some [ __ ] let me just
breathe and then let me just wait for a
minute and then let me try to laugh
about it in my head not at her you know
laugh about it and then wash my feelings
like I got a I got a make sure that this
is cool so I'm not returning it with
anger I got a I got a return it with
love so I'm like alright cool she says
she's mad what is she really talking
about okay I got remind myself she has
the best intentions she loves me
now approach it I have to remind myself
very consciously if I don't do that oh
boy fireworks dude it is it's why'd you
do it that way why did you do it that
way oh really oh really what's up bad
because like there's another level to
this [ __ ] too because sometimes you're
gonna do that right you're gonna go
whoosah let me try to understand this
girl let me give her love and she's
gonna take that love and then she's
gonna take a pocketknife and she's gonna
slash that love up and you still return
it back to you that oh that's happened
and that's that level three [ __ ] where
you know yeah okay I still got this [ __ ]
because this [ __ ] gonna [ __ ] get it
you know and I'm trying to unlock level
three right now yeah because it sucks
sometimes when you you do the right
thing and it still gets chewed up and
spoken spat right back my love is
unconditional I know you gotta take a
beating man just keep going my fingers
though like I always tell her and she
does this to him when I'm in the moment
I don't realize it that if I do that for
you I might expect you to do that for me
in my unreasonable time - yeah it's a
give it's a giving give yeah cuz I can't
do it all the invite to do it all the
time somebody gonna get a hook because
I'm gonna I'm gonna flip the [ __ ] out
like she and I got into an argument the
other day and it was a reoccurring
problem that she has know why we talked
about this at dinner but I looked at I
said this [ __ ] and this [ __ ] was [ __ ]
for real I was like this is for real for
outside hey you say you're not gonna do
it you do that one more time I'm gonna
flip them [ __ ] told her I'm gonna flip
the [ __ ] out so you watch
yourself i straight-up said that [ __ ]
and she goes well watch yourself yeah
and she's like well I guess we're not
really solving our problems if you give
me a warning and I was like I'm just
saying do it again and see what happens
you say you're not gonna do it I'm gonna
flip the [ __ ] out you know but that
wasn't really the solution it was just
me having to exercise patience to have
her understand what I was saying because
yeah and I started getting mad because I
assumed that what I was saying was easy
to understand but she just couldn't
comprehend it yeah and I to me it was
like this is pretty easy just it takes
patience man a lot of patience and I
just because I didn't I lacked patience
are you starting any more and more
frustrated cuz it's like in my mind I
was thinking oh you're just not
understanding on purpose because you
don't want to [ __ ] learn that's what
I think I say you want to try to learn
it a bit right way is that the right way
right yeah you you got X it's difficult
to realize that the person that you love
has no idea what this is
you know when it's so simple sometimes
yeah and then you got to remember
because what it does is it what I
realize is it destroys my image of her
I'm like there's no freaking way you're
this stupid yeah there's no way you
don't know it's in your face like how
can you not see this right and then I'm
like well I'm not doing a good service
as a boyfriend to approach her like that
like you know I can't I don't know but
then it just crushes your image of who
that person is and you're just in
disbelief you know but it doesn't solve
anything if you if you think or treat
her that way but that's I don't know why
we think that way it happens it's good
we're just caught up in the moment man
yeah and that's the human thing about it
too and I just don't want people to
think out there that all the stuff that
you see on media it's just that's how
things are all the time there's a reason
why you always see these videos where
people are like well we just broke up we
mentioned that - yeah it just doesn't
happen overnight like that it's like
when somebody breaks up right and you
guys know this [ __ ] there's a couple
that's been together for a very long
time they break up and all of a sudden
the the guy or the girl starts dating
somebody out of nowhere out of nowhere
and a weekend they're in a serious
relationship [ __ ] that person
had their sights on that [ __ ]
before you broke up and they either that
or they were cheating on you yeah these
are just facts I've seen it 10,000 times
yeah
I'm exaggerating but I've seen it almost
consistently it's like oh it's funny how
you just happen to end up with the guy
or the girl that you were working with
and the guy was worried about that you
guys were a hanging out with all the
time they're like no it just happened
organically it didn't happen organically
you already checked out of that
relationship months before yeah and then
when it finally gave you an out when
they gave you an out you took it and now
you're with that person it's the same
situation yeah it's it's just mental
weakness yeah cuz well I was watching
this video the other day about like
Centennial's like people that were over
a hundred years old you know and then
their life advice or like you know
things that they regret or whatever
they're just talking about their [ __ ]
and a lot of them were like you know
happiness in a relationship is just
they're like kids or people these days
to them everybody's a kid but they're
like oh yeah they're like younger people
he's like they're saying that they don't
work through [ __ ] and I'm like what do
you mean like work through [ __ ] right
and then they're basically what I got
from it is they're saying like
everything you can just work through
together and there's nothing that you
can't work through but no one takes the
time to work through things so it's all
it's all patience and just being able to
deal with the situation and making an
effort to work through it because back
then they're like what do you you can't
just get into divorce that easily you
you were forced to work through it so I
kind of feel like sometimes people had
it easier when they had less choices hmm
if you didn't get if you didn't have to
choose who you got with if you didn't
have an escape if there was no turning
back you just had to make it work with
this person you know maybe life would be
a lot easier yeah I mean choices do [ __ ]
up a lot of people you have too much
choices that's you know I'm this goes
into a completely different topic but
sometimes I feel like people sometimes
feel like they're temporary sadness is
depression because of the choices that
they're given now and I just get
overwhelmed yeah they have options and
stuff so like for example just um just
career choices yeah career choices were
a lot more limited back in the day and
now people are in an area
where they just feel like they don't
know what to do because of all the
options that they have I think that's
why people have commitment issues yeah
cuz it's like oh man if I get tied down
to one girl
that's one [ __ ] for the rest of my life
I want all the colors of the asses
there's a lot of guys out there like
that no and then I mean some some ladies
that enjoy a lot of variety know they or
they they might - cope of penis or they
might even be in a lackluster
relationship and in they're like
thinking what if there's someone better
you know they might be in a in a
relationship where the guys comfortable
and maybe he's not pursuing them as hard
anymore and I go well things used to be
awesome but then they're chasing that
romance they're chasing that fresh
feeling they want to be chased again you
know that could be true - people just
have to think sometimes - it's like a
lot of things like a lot of emotions are
temporary and you know it's very old
saying but the grass is always greener
on the other side and a lot of the times
people look at what somebody else has
and they think that that's what they
want
yeah and you're but you're foregoing a
lot of the things that are great right
now
yeah I know a lot of people and I'm
pretty sure a lot of you guys out there
know about the friend that cheated on
somebody that they were with and they
lost the person that they could have had
because of temporary happiness you know
just [ __ ] somebody and really what
did [ __ ] that person do for you and
it didn't and mind you - if you're in an
open relationship or whatever this isn't
really you're not in this conversation
but if you're in a committed
relationship and that happens in that
moment of passion or whatever you
decided to take a gamble and forgo
something that you know makes you happy
for this momentary happiness and a lot
of people tend to do that because
they're not thinking about whatever that
problem was maybe it was a fight that
you had with your partner maybe it was
something that wasn't going well instead
of addressing this problem I'm working
through it you decided to fill that hole
with something else yeah you know no pun
intended
but you started to fill that hole was
something that was very fleeting and
then you're also now that person who
gave you temporary happiness
isn't really the one for you they're
gone and now you're
go back to this thing it's not it's it's
basically self-sabotage yeah
from selfishness yeah really like you
just wanted that quick nut or whatever
it was yeah that quick attention it's an
escape yeah so like now with social
media - it's so easy to cheat and escape
and do whatever and and and and I think
people aren't really forced to sit down
and work their [ __ ] out because it's
hurtful it's hurtful to change yeah it's
it's difficult to change your own
behaviors but like you know the whole
upside to all of this is like it's like
the type of bond that you build through
struggle and like the [ __ ] that I
learned from being in a relationship
with Jess it's like I grew so much as a
human being and it's like yes there were
hard times but I look back and I'm
really thankful for those hard times cuz
it's like without that wake-up call [ __ ]
man there's no way I would have been
able to elevate in my brain and my life
and my thinking and my maturity and just
emotional capability and all that
none of that [ __ ] would have happened if
I didn't get with her she challenges you
yes in a good way
it is and it forces you to really and I
and I say this man it's like being in a
serious relationship for the first time
you don't learn jack [ __ ] about the
other person you actually learn more
about yourself you know it's unreal how
much I found out about myself and
specifically a lot of the spots that I
could improve on being with Mariel
because it's it's so weird how that
worked out like even yesterday um I
found out something in my head I found
out that originally it was Mariel that
had trouble saying I'm sorry and
apologizing it's actually flipped now
now I have trouble saying mmm so she's
good at it she's aware she is a lot more
aware than I am as though and the other
day I caught myself because you know the
Tesla whatever updated I'm giving him my
Tesla soon anyways but the Tesla updated
and I was reading stuff and then she
exit out of it I was like dude what the
hell I was reading that and then she
looked at me she goes you know you just
got mad at me the other day about
overreacting to small things was that
reaction worth it it has something she
[ __ ] got my ass and then I [ __ ] you
not I was so ashamed I couldn't even
look her in the eye look straight
forward I was like this [ __ ] [ __ ]
got my own wisdom
dude this woman how dare she and I was
so [ __ ] embarrassed I haven't felt
this way since I was like 6 years old
and I could not look her in the eye dude
and I was trying to joke play it off she
goes no I want a real apology and I I
couldn't do it because I was so
embarrassed that I was so embarrassed I
was like how dare you learn from the
life lesson I gave you and throw it back
in my face and I just sat there just oh
[ __ ] I'm so embarrassed right now I
embarrass myself I did something that I
told her not to do and then I try to
apologize to her and the apology was so
bad dude
cuz I was just squirming cuz I couldn't
do it I couldn't get over myself fairly
[ __ ] but she's always so funny
she got me so [ __ ] good dude ah but
you must have been proud of her though
oh yeah man I know I think back on and
I'm like do man now I'm being the
unreasonable but now she put me in place
and check me on this type of stuff yeah
but that's cool cuz it showed that I'm
with a woman who doesn't listen to me
she listens to me and you know in turn 2
I listen to her too so that's that's
something that you don't get with
superficial relationships you don't get
that you get a yes man or yes yes woman
or whatever and it's you know I think
the challenge is actually what I'm
addicted to oh yeah I think we're just
weird guys challenge me [ __ ] please you
know what it is I think I see myself
growing so even though I'm in pain at
times I know that it's worth it oh she's
your asian massage dude she's my she's
your Thai massage dude she's [ __ ]
bending your back and snapping you yeah
cuz there's I mean I can't there's a
reason why I can't quit even though like
my flighty personality like before her
man I'm just like banging girls and
whatever like I'm just like oh you're
not working out you're boring me move on
whatever move on yeah man like no one's
kept me so hooked like like sure we had
our problems and sure we might continue
having problems from time to time
but it's just this like weird sense of
need to be with her in its and it's not
this um what's the word it's not like
I'm just settled or I'm comfortable or
like whatever right it's this like we
both try to break up multiple times just
to work out we could yeah
something brought us back something
always like we just don't feel right
unless we are together and it's the
oddest thing too because you know one
moment we're we're hating each other's
guts and in the next moment we're
working really well together and
laughing and farting in front of each
other and doing whatever and and it just
gives me so much excitement in life
because there's been so many
relationships where it was so easy going
to where I'm completely uninterested you
know I think this is something that I
realized as well is that you we're with
somebody who you know fighting with
somebody to is also a sign that that
person cares I mean I know how yeah like
sick and sadistic that sounds yeah but
that's that's what you get in a
committed relationship you get somebody
that cares about you 24/7
yeah and I felt that way when I was sick
and then Mariel came over and she was
well are you sick and she was all the
way on the other side of the city and
she goes well I'm gonna come over and I
was like no I'm sick don't come over she
comes over she brings all this medicine
she lays next to me and she's like you
know pets my head that's my chest helps
me to relax and be calm it's not
something that I ever got with the girl
that I was just talking to yeah you know
like we had those momentary just just
cycles of happiness right before we make
out whatever we [ __ ] whatever it doesn't
matter but then when it came down to
helping me out that's not somebody that
I would ever depend on yeah but this
woman that I would fight with all the
time that we would bicker just just go
back and forth on stupid [ __ ] she would
drop anything that she's doing just to
make sure that I'm okay yeah and that is
the positive side of these long-term
relationships because sometimes when
people who are in these short-term
relationship they say well why do you
want to just stick to one dick or one
[ __ ] for the rest of your life and you
know sex is such a small part of that it
is it's having somebody that you can
look on and depend on for the rest of
your life and eventually that person who
you're
just partners with actually becomes your
family and that's where that
unconditional love comes in it's like oh
[ __ ] you're not
Muriel my girlfriend you're Muriel my
partner my family my team my ta yeah I'd
do anything for you and even we would
talk about you know finances sometimes
she's like okay well you know I'll pay
you back for this I don't want to owe
you anything and I got really mad when
she would say that because I I when I
heard that I heard oh we're not a team I
was like hey don't worry about that
stuff yeah
paying me back whatever all this other
stuff I don't care we're a team
you know yeah so you don't have to work
it look at me as if you owe me something
because I did you a favor this is this
is not how this relationship works yeah
how it works is that if I do something I
give you something it's because you're
my family member I never expect to see
that back yeah I I do it because I do it
because I care about you and if you're
tallying up points of oh well you did
this favor for me I I don't want to owe
you that we're not on the same page
anymore and that actually made me upset
you know and for her I think at that
time when she had that conversation she
wasn't really thinking about it like
that she just probably didn't want to
overstep her boundaries yeah I get oh it
always comes from a good place yeah it's
like yeah I mean same thing with me and
Jess man it's like pretty awesome that
we we never fought over money know her
chores over any of that [ __ ] team it is
a team like she knows that I just suck
yeah but what I what I'm super thankful
for is that she picks up my slack and I
pick up hers no and we never fought
about that that's something that is just
like she never got angry at me kept
complaining or nothing and then like I
don't do that to her either we'll fight
about other stupid [ __ ] about like her
not believing in my sugar cane dream I
mean holding it against there forever
yeah or like her you know being upset at
food or something like that you know
like it's stupid it's really stupid but
I think at the end of the day when we
looked at our relationship like we're
like damn thank God we don't fight over
the normal people [ __ ] like most people
are fighting over money most people are
fighting over like cheating
or like you know like hiding money from
each other or not paying the you know
breakers there's a there's huge issues
you're not fighting over that we're just
fighting over stupid [ __ ] yeah and but
the main things like loyalty [ __ ]
honor
like you know integrity honesty all
those things you know I I don't ever
take her for granted for any of that
[ __ ] all that stuff is like a hundred
percent so it's to me I think the core
values of a human being like I highly
highly respect her you know and so aside
from that like everyone's gonna have
certain differences right yeah it's just
we're not all created the same yeah
arguably I say that the reason why I do
like Muriel so much or I love her so
much because she is different from me if
I had the same person and you you I know
you guys have similar traits but you
guys are still very different Peter yeah
very [ __ ] different you know like
number one just look at your room and
look at hers do you know him was a
[ __ ] disaster
yo your room looks like there was a
crack rock than a copy to define to
[ __ ] put somebody in jail and they
couldn't find it to say their [ __ ]
life like your room is crazy dude I was
like your how the [ __ ] did this man own
a successful business dude huh what in
the hell is going on in here dude but
your shits wild but you could tell that
that's your room cuz the rest of your
apartments so [ __ ] and [ __ ] span dude
unreal dude
yeah but I'm learning better cleaning
habits and stuff because of her yeah and
you know what I like like I said what I
love her about it is just that I've
never been in trouble like she accepts
me for like my craziness and she lets me
have my crazy space yeah and I let her I
mean I actually grew up in a very clean
home so like her standard of cleanliness
it doesn't freak me out my mom's very
clean OCD type like everything had to be
perfect right so that is actually very
comforting to me
the mess that I caused in my own room
that freaks me out but it's also
comfortable too yeah
so then I have my office space in my own
room and I can do whatever the [ __ ] I
want there but it kind of reminds me of
how I grew up like my mom was like it's
your room you do what you want my room
went to [ __ ] but then the rest of the
house was like synchronising taken care
of so like I just kind of like it just I
feel comfortable everybody has that
comfort thing too and I realized this
about my Honda Element today
the reason why cuz I'm very I'm a very
particular human being right and the one
thing that I don't have to be put in
because I'm a particular human being
when things go in disarray and it
bothers me a lot so you got that OCD a
little bit exactly so the Honda Element
is something that can be in disarray
that takes me from point A to point B
that I don't have to worry about
so whether somebody comes and they dent
that car they [ __ ] it up like some [ __ ]
breaks on it who cares yeah but mind you
like my Tesla when something good
somebody puts a debt it I stare at it
really like it bothers me and I even for
me like here's something weird too cuz
it's a lease right and there's coverage
in the point where there's if there's
like a quarter-sized dent and it's fine
yeah I'm still gonna get that fixed
because it bothered me I can't I can't I
can't stared it but I don't have that
with it with the with a Honda Element so
it actually gives me sanity because in
this city if you have a nice car just
know it's gonna get [ __ ] it's gonna get
ya in the first month I got a little
dent some boom
right yeah on the door yeah yep it was
crazy
it happens do so that's what the Honda
Element does to me it actually subsides
that OCD behavior that I have were
obsess about something being a certain
way because of its value and the the
Honda Element is worth like five six
grand and it runs perfectly fine but if
somebody dents it or even if I [ __ ] it
up oh well you know move on putting more
money into it doesn't make any sense
like if I fix it let's say I fixed that
dent it was 400 bucks well guess what I
just fixed up 10% of what the cars worth
on nothing for you it's it's how
expensive things are then huh
yeah for its expense so it's like I see
I could have the most expensive [ __ ]
I'll [ __ ] that [ __ ] up I don't know what
my thing is what I prize and and like
want to take care of and keep clean and
and perfect and things like that what
about your guns yeah but I if it does
get messed up it doesn't hurt me that
much yeah yeah I I've I like things
organized because when things are
organized and done the right way
it helps organize my mind and thoughts
yeah I can see that yeah yeah it's it's
if you live in a nice clean environment
your mind is like that - like I'm a
scatterbrain that's why my top my world
is caddy it's good all over the place
yeah yeah but it helps when Jess sends
up the house for me yeah then I feel Zen
in my head and it helps her to Zen it up
for herself - yeah if you touch that
[ __ ] it's gonna everything's gonna go
crazy she's like don't you dare touch
this [ __ ] because I get anxiety when I'm
cleaning I get stressed dude oh really
I'm starting to get pissy like yeah if I
play music and I'm like washing dishes
or whatever it's like lying yeah but I
feel like I'm wasting my life away I'm
like this is not making me any money
yeah this is not doing anything what's
the purpose of this other than just it
being clean yeah and then I don't know
why I don't know but the funny thing is
I'll clean the [ __ ] out of my guns yeah
cuz it's important to you yeah I'll
scrub the [ __ ] out of it and whatever
like I'll do things like that
I like planting things in the dirt yeah
I'm watering in it taking care of that
yeah I don't know why like I don't know
why things get destroyed whenever I go
into a room I destroy the [ __ ] out of
that room it's cuz it's your [ __ ]
space dude it's your Honda Element dude
it is my but the world is my Honda
Element my clothes everything I don't
like a disaster I know my room by
watches are all scratched up damn what
is it I don't even know what I don't
know what my thing is like what I don't
want this to get all [ __ ] up yeah
that's a probably a good thing to add
though that means like you don't you
don't put a lot of value into material
things which is a good thing yeah I like
material things but yeah I don't um I
don't care if it gets destroyed the next
day yeah [ __ ] shoes man that doesn't
you know what my phone stays pretty good
quality quality I never crack it or
whatever but that's about it
yeah I mean you're pretty good with that
oh [ __ ]
well
this is an hour in [ __ ] 9 or 10
minutes oh yeah man you guys got to just
[ __ ] hear a lot of wisdom out of
everything that we've learned in our
relationships man if I had to sum it up
though all it is is just accepting the
good and the bad yeah patience patience
patience is a big thing everyone says
the same [ __ ] you know what's crazy
though is you hear these things right
patience acceptance whatever and you go
yeah I know we don't we don't know you
gotta [ __ ] go and you go oh this is
patience oh my [ __ ] god relationships
is something that even as we tell you
this it's just a heads up but you're not
gonna know until you experience you bet
everyone has to do do it yeah but I
guarantee you though like you get
through it you start to experience
another level of closeness that is just
irreplaceable and it's [ __ ] amazing
you're gonna you're gonna you own learn
today that's what's gonna happen you're
gonna look back at this podcast and
you're gonna go that's what they were
talking about when I wanted to choke
this [ __ ] out this is what they did Joe
we're talking about patience French
patience and and there's there's also
another one where people are they can't
even get in a relationship in the first
place
oh yeah there's a lot of people that
just so lonely and they they don't even
know where to start
yeah we could we could cause that's
another one too yeah all right job well
that ends this episode of genius writing
podcast soon remember you guys could
catch your own every single audio
platform out there we're talking about
iTunes Spotify stitch or a cast box
there's a lot more out there but if you
are on those apps give us that five star
we need it very much and I'm gonna beg
you for it because I can and I have no
[ __ ] shame please do it please please
please please go on iTunes right now put
five stars and if you're watching this
on youtube remember this is a very
interactive space leave comments about
the stuff you want us to talk about this
topic came about actually because you
guys requested it even though it was
something I didn't want to address
myself but you guys mentioned it so it
works out that way right so well yeah
we'll catch you guys next time thank you
very much bye bye bass